my first question for you is
was the croods and also your star wars
voice work enough to fully prepare you
for this or is there anything about
filming raya that required a bit of a
learning curve yeah i feel like all of
those characters were really different
um i think that i
had a lot of fun playing raya because i
got to do a lot of things that i haven't
done before
um and there was definitely still things
to learn i think
i think on any new job that i take
there's always going to be things to
learn
so uh yeah i'm really grateful that the
people around me
not just the the directors but also the
writers and
the cast everyone was sort of you know
so welcoming and we all were able to
uh feel like the environment was one
that we were allowed to fail in
um so it was a lot of fun it was just so
much fun to
to find this character together um yeah
is there any example you have of a time
where you thought you were failing
and they kind of talked you up and then
in the end you realized you were doing
the right thing anyway
uh i i know i know times that i i was
feeling that i
um they might have talked me up but it
was definitely wrong
um like i remember
i was gosh i had so much fun improvising
during this but there's a moment where
raya meets baby noy
and um i just remember i don't think i
even said anything but i remember like
trying to physically get into that
moment and physically
understand what was going on in ra's
mind and i remember like picking up a
fake baby
and just being like who do you belong to
and then the directors were just like
you shouldn't i know it's a fake baby
but don't don't shake don't shake the
baby
so there's definitely weird awkward
moments like that for sure
were you at least filming yourself while
you were doing your voice recording work
at home
so we can have this b-roll on like a dvd
extra menu
yes there is a camera that captures
everything it captures your entire
performance and it's because they want
to use
um that footage to animate the
characters
so yeah somewhere that footage exists
and i'm very sorry i
i apologize for it the important thing
is that it's released for our own
amusement one day
yeah yeah there you go so this next
one's a big one right here because
you're playing the first
southeast asian disney princess and
you're also no stranger to achieving
first in the industry
in general so what have you learned from
your prior
first that now you can apply to this
first in order to make the most of the
experience for the folks who have been
waiting for this to happen for so long
and also
for yourself good question
um yeah i think the most important thing
i've learned about being the first
anything
is just that you want to make sure
you're not the last of whatever that
thing is
um making sure that as you are sort of
opening the door that you're leaving it
open for others to follow
um and also gosh the most important
thing is to
really enjoy every single moment because
these moments are
once in a lifetime and they're fleeting
um
yeah i really just want to live every
one of these moments to the fullest and
recognize
that this is a miraculous experience
and it doesn't really make sense and
it's so much bigger than me um
and being able to acknowledge all of
those things is a
yeah that's big for me i am a
big believer that you're gonna keep
doing what you just said you wanted to
do with that
uh to wrap up here is there any new tool
in your voice acting toolkit so to speak
that you can credit to rya and now bring
on to
future opportunities like monsters at
work and then some
um i think that uh i learned a lot from
being raya
i think um one specific skill i learned
is how to make a very convincing uh
grunt for those fighting scenes so uh
yeah i hope to bring that with me in the
future
for sure it's an important thing that
nobody thinks about i feel like it's
those
those efforts that are probably the
toughest thing in the bunch
yup yup it's weird i'll tell you that
well you are stellar in this movie it's
really phenomenal and
i can't wait for everyone out there to
experience it so thank you so much
congratulations thank you so much